These are my friends,
Shawn and Jackson.
Jackson's a new driver.
Normally, that's an exciting
time,
but when you're black...
- You know, when I'm--when I'm
driving, you know, it's crazy,
They actually have a name
for it: driving while black.
Whenever I see cops,
I always make sure to put
my hands on top of the wheel,
make sure, you know,
they don't see me if I'm on my
phone, anything like that.
I just make sure I'm
following all of the rules,
make sure there's no
reason for them to pull me over.
- The fear of every time he
leaves the house,
is he coming back?
Is very real for me.
- I know you're worried
about what may happen
to Jackson, but do you ever
worry about what Jackson may do?
Maybe he might go out
there just ghost ride the whip.
- What is it called?
- Ghost riding the whip.
Yeah, I don't know.
- That's standard
high school stuff now.
To ghost ride the whip is to
dance next to or on top of your
car while still moving,
ideally with many friends
surrounding and
rap music blaring.
Jackson,
you gotta tell the people
at home what kinda car you got.
- 2005 Ford 500.
- That's a safe car,
but what if I told y'all
I could make it safer?
- Anything that will
bring him home safe and sound,
I'm all about it.
[funky music]
To help Jackson out,
I headed down to Roadstarr,
where I hooked up with my boy
Hassan.
He customizes cars like
Quincy Jones customizes beats.
He just be
layin' that magic down.
What's some of the craziest
things
you've ever done to a car?
- Making Tyga's Audi R8 gold.
- Why do you love
customizing car so much?
- I think it's the challenge,
just the fact that, you know, if
you got a crazy idea and we've
been able to fulfill it,
and you come to
pick up your car,
and your jaws dropping like,
"Oh, my God."
- So you do it for that?
- Do it for that.
- For that reaction.
- And the check.
- Well, listen, man,
I got a very big project.
We all remember "Pimp My Ride."
Well, this is
"Woke My Ride."
I need you and Roadstarr to make
this car safe
for a young black man in 2017.
So I need y'all to trick it out.
I showed Hassan my plans,
and he and his guys got to work.
[rock music]
♪ ♪
- Can I show y'all what we did?
- Yes, yes.
- Yes.
- Come on over here.
So, first thing we did
is gave you cameras, dawg.
Because the cops like to lose
or delete body camera footage.
Well, damn they cameras.
We got cameras on top of
cameras.
Camera, camera,
camera, camera, camera, camera.
There's cameras
all over this thing.
You might also notice we put
a white woman in your passenger
side, because statistically,
white women get
pulled over the least.
Ski rack, because no criminals
are doing stuff in the snow.
You ever seen that before, dawg?
- Mm-mm.
- Exactly.
James did it.
Come on now.
What are we looking at?
That says, "Don't pull us over.
"We just a family on the way to
LEGOLAND to do some
nonthreatening stuff."
"We back the badge."
Pretty much saying, "Hey, cops,
we on the same team."
It's like Kobe pulling over
Shaq.
Bad example.
It's like
LeBron pulling over Kyrie.
You feel me, Shawn and Jackson?
- I do.
- You feel me?
Let's keep it going.
You might notice some diffuser
oil so the cops can't claim that
they smell marijuana smoke,
not in this car.
It only smells like
Burke Williams spa in here.
They're not going to pull you
over.
They're gonna meditate.
- And I put your
Miranda rights on the back seat.
Check it out,
because the cops, they
have this tendency to
not read you your rights.
But now, they in your back seat.
What does
number one say, Jackson?
- "You have the
right to remain silent."
- Yep, you do.
Now, the crowning
achievement.
- I can't wait.
- See-through glove compartment.
Ha-ha-ha-haaaa.
We killed it.
- Oh, my God.
That is so clever.
- Now they can see your
registration, because when you
reach, that's when
they start saying you might
be reaching for something else.
Now, also,
special bonus feature.
Whoo!
Me and Roadstarr,
produced a biography of your
life up to this point
with all the highlights,
all the positive images,
just in case the media tries to
smear your image like they
did with Mike Brown and them.
So boom,
we just woke yo car.
♪ ♪
Don't you ride
in anything else but this.
It's too dangerous
out here in 2017.
- Listen to this.
- That's right.
- You keep your cameras,
your ski rack, your stickers,
your diffuser oil, everything.
- And your white girl.
Listen to Mom.
- I mean, you covered every
base.
Sad state of affairs that
you had to do that,
but if it'll bring my son home,
I'm all about that.
- This is one of
those cars where, like,
his curfew should be later
now because the car so safe.
- Well, I don't know about that.
I don't know--
- You know what I mean?
- No, I don't know about that.
No, no, no.
- Okay, okay.
I tried, Jackson.
- Nice try, though.
- I tried, Jackson.
- Nice try, yeah.